[Music]
the perception of intelligence is
extremely important in human evolution
and as a result pretty important to your
life psychology shows that in text when
a middle initial is used there are
positive evaluations of a person's
intellect and abilities middle initials
are generally saved for more formal
contexts like John F Kennedy one study
asked participants to choose academic
team partners and those with middle
initials were more likely to be chosen
middle initial equals increased
perceived status Hey reservation for
Louie P no one else get salary
I really think no the big and faster
golf tournament was so strong what about
Lily s
dollar in it has been found that when
something seems more scientific and has
a greater power to persuade in a study
67% of participants believe the specific
piece of information without arrived but
if a grass was added then ninety-six
percent of the participants believe it
even though it was the same information
OMG we should totally watch Magic Mike
it got 80 percent on Rotten Tomatoes I
don't know dude dancing I don't think
that's for me no yeah neither grow did I
mention I got a eighty percent on Rotten
Twitter okay yeah yeah I go Lilly what
are you trying to do science a trend I
like about life okay I want to be stupid
no you just have to speak expressively
and people will believe you in
scientific fact
really whatever wise the girl superwoman
when two people have the same things to
say it one modulates their speak and
keeps positive to a minimum they come
across is more knowledgeable in a recent
study participants were asked to present
to a hypothetical employer and both of
yous various pitches tones and volumes
were perceived as more thoughtful
intelligent and left a better overall
impression that okay I have no idea what
I just said there's actually a
correlation between what a university
professor where and how the students
learn in fact if instructors were more
formal attire the students are less
likely to misbehave stereotypes play a
big role in how people perceive you and
there's a pretty big stereotype that
smart people wear glasses in fact
studies even show that those people who
wear glasses are
and more intelligence I finish the most
fascinating article about Isis and the
impact it's having on Lebanon borders I
mean will the sanctions work have you
read it um yes obviously I'm fully aware
of all issues related to the Middle East
are you sure you've actually read it
yeah oh my god you're so far you
definitely have three arms I don't fully
understand the Iran deal the ability to
accurately assess someone else's
intelligence is of great evolutionary
importance you don't want to mate with
the dummy studies have found that when
people observe headshots the ones that
are rated as highly intelligent are more
often smiling so show them pearly whites
I hope we're making a good impression is
they really want her to think that were
some heart keep smiling she's not even a
sub science is so smart they even look
intelligent in real life she walked to
alcohol consumption and cognitive
impairment go together known as the
imbibing idiot by a studies found that
managers perceive candidates to be less
intelligent if they ordered a wine over
a soda another study found that those
who are actually just holding alcoholic
beverages were perceived to be less
intelligent than those who are not hey
are you from doing your bags I'm from
Toronto but I'm just visiting LA I'm
kind of girls you in - well I'm
scientists so I really like smart girl
oh no weird because just happens to be
one of those ones did you know the
mitochondria is the powerhouse
okay thanks for watching we hope you
liked that video make sure you subscribe
to Lilly's an amazing champagne awesome
comedy hilarious videos we'll put the
links in the description to that thank
you so much for being here chance I
cannot do it what do you do
[Music]